some glue some other hair in it to this
it didn't work out so that's why it's
all gluey like
my son wanted me to do my hair like that
like this he said mommy do it lola
it's fun yeah i see my ski i see my kid
all the time i talk to him all the time
how many kids do you have four my oldest
just turned 24 my birthday's up 31st
i'll be 44. been out here for like
almost 30 years
on and off 30 years on skid row yeah
so i started off macarthur park well
hollywood air hollywood area
i did escort service um
so you're an escort from what was the
escort from 13
yeah and the men knew that i was that
age
they would they would yeah there seems
to be a market they would specifically
specifically call for me
which is kind of kind of sad i think
about it now it's kind of sad but
at the same time i was thinking well you
know if they want to be with somebody
young then
at least they're with me and not with
somebody you know younger or whatever
but anyways yeah yeah so like i get i
get paid between three and five hundred
dollars
a day sometimes i didn't even have to do
anything
it was just arm candy going to parties
or whatever being
like there going out to dinner
were you saving money back then no
because i had a pimp
i had a pimp i had a pimp i honestly i
it's a story i really you know haven't
really thought about
in a long time um
so i had i i was i grew up in oxnard
you know oxnard and
navy base poor whitening me
come from middle upper class family was
very secluded
very um closed
our family was very close and
closed-minded
um if you're of another race
my grandfather was really racist
like i don't know if it was intentional
or what but
my grandfather's irish i'm a time my
grandma's
italian and my dad my dad dad i barely
got to meet him
in 2015. but he's indian
so it's like imagine cherokee indian
italian and irish
three drinkers
allbad.com like all bad i was severe
alcoholic
really bad and i got in the in
in i want to be in the in crowd i was
straight a student
straight a had a scholarship with a
philharmonic orchestra
and i dropped out of school in ninth
grade because i didn't want um
i want to be popular you know and i
never
never dated like never had a boyfriend
never went to prom
never went to dances never did none of
that because i wasn't allowed to do any
of that
so dropped out and i ran away
right from home i ran away all the way
here to
to hollywood and then from on and off
for about a year year and a half
i was here and then i went i got away
from him
from the the pimp got away from him
and went up to grand rapids michigan
i don't know how the hell i got over
there i know i got in i was in big rigs
you know
hitchhiking all the way up there then i
got busted for um
being um running a prostitution ring
they tried to get me for running
prostitution ring because they got me
in an adult in a dope house and um
i was the only one there i was running
this house i was there madam or whatever
you want to call it and
i was there and then i they said they
were giving me 10 to 15 years per person
that was up in that house and i started
crying i said i'm a minor i'm a minor
please oh
my god and i was sure enough they
checked on us
missing and exploited children and i was
there on the internet
my grandmother so how does a you're 13
when the pimp
i was 13. how did the tim approach you
well i he was my so-called boyfriend
like i wanted to be in he had the coke
i was doing a lot of coke then a lot a
lot of crack a lot of coke
like and when he got me where he wanted
he had me chained to
where i couldn't leave like literally on
my foot
in the hotel room this hollywood
celebrity hotel in hollywood off of
cherokee or something like that on
highland like around that area
um so i was there like
he would have the people come there
because
i tried to get away once and i didn't
make it but
he um he would have the people come
there and he would get paid good money
you know how many guys a day would you
entertain
between three and five thirteen-year-old
girl
13. and you did this until when
like almost 15. and then
i ran i got away because he sold me to
somebody
and they let me go
yeah so he sold me to this guy i guess
this guy he was
um so somebody stepped in egyptian it
was egyptian or something like that
he was a date so he paid good money for
me
he paid like almost five five thousand
to ten thousand dollars
to get you away from the town to take me
and as soon as he took me he drove me
away and he let me out
that's sweet and
i should have went home i should have
went back to my grandparents but i was
too much of a drug addict then yeah i
couldn't do it
and i was just thinking where i was
going to get my next high
what i was going to do so i hitchhiked
you know and a lot of the big rig
drivers they do a lot of coke
to stay awake they did a lot of cooks
stay awake and i would
go with them and you know i figured well
you know if they're going to drive me
here
you know the ticket costs this much this
is what i'm going to do for that you
know
at least i get to sleep they're going to
feed me you know and
so i thought it was a win-win you know
on everything
until um
yeah until that happened and and then my
i
i got arrested and went to big jail my
first time in big jail i was
crying it was all bad
and then my uncle my uncle's a sheriff
for ventura county sheriff's department
he flew from here there to grand rapids
michigan to pick me up
on the airplane and
he's he's he's
he's he's very bitter towards me now um
i i haven't seen my family in a minute
because i don't like to be put down i
don't like them to see me different than
what they knew me as before i don't want
my cousins to see me different
um i don't know i'm ashamed
more than anything but i was doing
really good until the last two years
like two years ago i left my my my my
son's dad my youngest dad
because he cheated on me he said i
wasn't good enough for him i was real
fat
i was like almost 300 pounds
[Music]
so i decided to start doing crystal
meth and crack together
i did it for three weeks i did not sleep
21 days i look like
a serpent my eyes were yellow i i got
cellulitis because i got poison from
like
all the drugs that i was doing i didn't
know how to do it
and it was really bad i had a fever of
106.
and i almost died but you know
that's when i quit crack but you lost
the weight
i lost 100 pounds in three weeks it's a
hell of a
hell of a diet drug i didn't eat i
didn't eat i didn't drink i didn't
nothing i could literally feel my skin
eating itself
like like like stuff crawling all in
your skin
all over everywhere it was it was really
bad nobody taught me how to smoke
crystal
they never taught me how i just thought
oh you just do the same like correct no
you don't do you still have teeth huh i
have social
just a fat yeah but i had those before
all this happened
you know um i had
a set of partials but
they don't they don't these are your
actual teeth you got my teeth these are
your teeth so
your teeth survived all the cracking
well they're actually they hurt these
i don't have all of them i just have my
front ones but that's still better than
a lot of other people yeah most people
are looking at their teeth i could have
them taken out i should
really because they hurt you know a lot
of my teeth hurt but
so we know about your teen years what
about your 20s and 30s how old are you
i'm i'll be 44 on the 31st so 20s 30s
and now you're 40.
what what kind of stuff you've been
doing well during those days okay when i
was
i got i had my i got married when i was
18
to a trip i got him his papers and i got
off the street
so i thought hey this is still but i was
still
dipping into crack i lived in lafayette
park
um lafayette in macarthur park area um
so i lived over there with him and then
i got pregnant
and i had my daughter a week before i
turned 21.
and i never had a real job until
i got with him so i had a job at
universal studios and then i got
pregnant i had to quit my job
and i had her week before i turned 21
then when she was three
i left him because he was abusive like
he was very abusive to me
um when she was three i left
i went back i went to georgia my
family's in georgia
and i stayed there for about almost two
a year
and then the the federal agents the
marshals came
and got me for my job i was i was a
waitress to cook
at waffle house in buford georgia and
so i was there and they came and they
picked me up
and they said you got fed you got you're
one
you're a wanted woman so they flew me
back they extradited me
from georgia to here for what extradited
no
what for for kidnapping
oh my daughter likes i was married
married to him and i didn't tell him
where i was taking her so
technically he needed to know where i
was taking her and he didn't even want
my daughter
you know he just did it because you know
that that's that's what hurt me
the most is if that happened
so he played the part of mr goody goody
bringing the bible with him to court all
the time
i was like gosh dang i'm like god if
these are your disciples
you need to shoot him in the head you
know like seriously
seriously he's like like there with the
bible and stuff
and i was like if they only seen the
house if they only see what he does
behind closed doors
you know he only sees how he really
treats a woman
like they who locked me in the house he
had a padlock on the outside of my doors
my windows everything in the house locks
on the outside that he had locked
well i couldn't get to so like when he
would leave and he would unplug the
phone
all that like i didn't have a cell phone
or nothing i didn't have no contact with
nobody
like during those three years three four
five years that i was with him
because i was from 18 to 21 18
19 20 20 3 years three years i was with
him for three years and
it's the worst three years of my life
but i've seen a lot of stuff you know
you know sabo salvadorian um
so like i pretty much seen a lot of
stuff
and then when i left him went there i
actually died back here did a year and a
half in county jail
that's when county jail was over here at
twin towers
in a year and a half i was a trustee i
did that front area
of the twin towers that has all the
flowers and the cement and all that i i
helped do that i was one of the trustees
that did it
my name's carved in there somewhere on
that thing on the cement
and so and then from then i was
i was supposed to see my kid when i got
i was supposed to see my kid
but the the media the mediator was
him so how am i gonna have a mediator
that's the same person that
you know that i'm my ex how are you
gonna have a mediator that's him
you need to have somebody else different
but i think he paid him off
you know anyway so i didn't see i see my
daughter
once when she was little and i barely
really
i barely barely got to see her when my
son
when i got pregnant with my son
and my son's nine so like i've only
known
known her or her whereabouts for nine
years
because my son was like my son was under
i was pregnant and then i went to see
her
and she didn't want to see me she blames
me for everything bad that happened on
that i wasn't there to help like the
sexual abuse
she was sexually abused my daughter
she's 20
23 23 or 24
i'm not sure should we before i turn 21
yeah
she's 23 um she's a nurse
she she achieved what she needed to do
she looks just like me but real skinnier
like hella skinny
and tall she's taller than me and
straight
light brown hair that's that's all i
remember
my kid and then i had another kid she's
four seventeen
how many kids though four two girls
first
her she's gonna she's 23 and then i have
a 17 year old and a 13 year old that i
have with one guy
with my my my other baby dad so i have
three baby dads
and i have a nine year old that i was
actually able to raise
you know that's still in my life that
loves the hell out of me
that wants me to do good that blames his
dad for everything that i'm doing
because it is his fault
he said if that if you didn't if you
didn't go with that lady my mom would
still be here
he blames him for a lot of stuff my
son's going through a lot of
psychological stuff
right now a lot of depression he sees a
therapist
um he's
autistic he's on the autism
spectrum he's on the spectrum but very
very low
with the asperger's um
but he doesn't his dad doesn't his dad
would always complain about the way that
i was
raising my kid and
he does worse he yells at my kid my
kid's nine years old
like when i go there to visit he starts
yelling at him if he
doesn't wash his hands properly or puts
touch something or puts oil on something
it's like
really he's a kid you know and then he
[ __ ] at me he starts cussing at me
and i'm like you know what i'm
so glad and then this came along this
hotel i've been there for about a month
month and a half and it's like the first
thing that has ever gone
right since i've been out here
like really correct the way that it's
supposed to happen
because they're gonna put me in a
shelter like on 14th and paloma and i
said no
i don't want to be around i'm very very
personal like i don't like people
knowing my business i'm a little
bit messy like not dirty messy but like
unorganized messy clothes everywhere
like all that kind of stuff makeup
everywhere
you know and i like to wash clothes by
hand
so like my room has all these clothes
hanging up in my room because i wash my
hand
i like to do i like to wash by hand i
don't know it's just
oh i don't know why were you homeless
before that
yeah in a tent yeah i had
i had a tent and then i built a house i
built one by the free
by the railroad tracks by the parole
office i built one out of wood and then
i got jealous people and then they tore
my stuff down and
ripped everything up and i was like
whatever you guys can have the street
you guys want that you can have it it's
okay don't worry
and right when i figured out you know
what
just let everything go because none of
the stuff that i have i paid for
nothing found in the trash it was given
to me
everything that i buy is bought with
recycled money
always it's never from my pocket it's in
my pocket but it's never from my pocket
it's from a can or whatever that i turn
in for that money
it's all recycled everything
so anything and everything you will ever
see me where
i found most likely i found on the
street like all this
was thrown in the trash like all this
the shorts
shoes everything in the trash
like people just don't like i have ever
comedy
and finch i have juicy couture perfume
i have all that yeah i look good smell
good all that
and don't have to pay for nothing once i
start buying stuff from the store then
as
[ __ ] starts going bad for me so i gotta
i gotta
rewind and take it back and then
use it for something else like i've i
had to learn the value of money
this time that's what i know that i had
to learn the value of money because i
was spending money
so badly when i was in this other
relationship with my son's dad i was
with him 12 years almost 12
years clean and sober
i was a nurse i worked for kaiser
i worked for ralph's in hollywood
did in-home care hospice care
and i lost it all because i
started getting high and drinking
because i was depressed because
my ex is a liar that's all
you know he's a liar the whole
relationship was fake to him
he felt sorry for me whatever you know
you've had quite a lot did i discuss him
you've had quite a life for a 44 year
old
whoo i've been killed twice i was dead
literally
what do you think is
put you on this path i mean because your
story involves prostitution and drug
addiction
and what homelessness what put me on
this path abusive relationships and all
this stuff
what put me on this path is
for me to be testimony
i think for me to be testimony and proof
that you know what
as much curve balls as much [ __ ]
strikes out
that i got thrown i'm still here i'm
still here
i have my teeth i don't have scars on my
face
i don't have any fingers cut off so that
means i'm not a thief
you know i'm not a snitch you know i'm
none of that
i'm just me i just gotta be honest
truthful
tell the truth and whatever i say in
behind
a person's back i can stay in front of
their face
like if somebody asked me something okay
yeah bring him here let me see come on
bring him here
now they're scared of me they don't take
my stuff
like my bike i had it locked up over
here on the other street with a drinky
dink lock
they didn't take it cause they know i'll
take all theirs
or set all their stuff on fire do you
have any regrets
my my regret
the regret that i do have in my life is
no i don't i don't have any regrets
the only regret is that i wasn't able to
be there for my
mom and my grandma when they passed
that's the only thing really but
everything else
that's the way god wanted it to happen
because
otherwise it wouldn't have happened the
way it happened i just have to learn how
to be with sit
i had to learn how to sit with myself i
had to learn how to
value money like i'm broke i'm total
broke right now
like total broke but i have everything i
need they give you three meals at this
hotel
good food not no nasty food like
jailhouse food
it's good food they have actual cooks
you know you get three meals
what more can you ask for cable tv
king-sized bed
yeah there's a curfew oh wow there's a
curfew but people work postmates they
work
door dash they work all that i'm in and
out all night
they don't care as long as you're it's
all how you carry yourself
like looking at me i clean up real good
like right now i look like crap
but like i can clean up real good you
won't even be able to tell that i'm
homeless
or that i'm high as [ __ ] part of my
language
but you can't you you wouldn't be able
to tell
crystal math yeah but i haven't i
haven't done any since like two days
i'm i'm because i haven't had i haven't
really have money
you know i've had more prior other
priorities um
like like i went to the store
i got well right now i just
had a little i had like about fifteen
dollars i bought an outfit
does that mean that you could quit
crystal meth if you wanted to oh i can
i've i've quit for a whole week if
you've gone two days now
i've gone i've gone yet i mean i'm kind
of craving it a little bit i'm tired
i've been up my mind is
i'm like adhd like big time my mind is
total i'm thinking about what i'm going
to gotta
gotta do later what i gotta do tomorrow
and
when i when i go to sleep i really don't
sleep because my mind is still
working like i dream about my what i'm
gonna do
the next day like it's all in my head as
my mind needs to like rewind and
like relax all this out here believe it
or not is very stressful
oh yeah like for especially for a female
by yourself
like single i don't i don't want no
boyfriend i don't need no guy
why i need a guy i do a lot more by
myself than they do in their whole life
you know i do more in one day than they
do in a whole week
you know like and then you get the
weirdos
like weirdo weirdos that like
weird that don't want to pay nothing you
know that just want to sit and smoke
your dope on your pipe and what you suck
their dick i'm like what the hell you
let me do that [ __ ]
get that [ __ ] out of my face
prostitution's still part of your life
sometimes
i have regulars that i've known for
years
you know if i see a regular or if i'm
really
really in need of money i will turn a
date
i'm not saying i don't i use rubbers all
the time i have rubbers in my purse
you know um
you can't put nothing past you know i'm
not ashamed of what i do
but i'm not gonna front myself off
and make myself look like that because
people certain people see me a different
way
like like over by macarthur park they
don't know that i do that
when i go over that way i'm i carry
myself different
you know they don't know so i don't want
them i'm ashamed of that
that part of my life the prostitution
i'm ashamed of that especially when i
see
see people that i've dated and then i
see their families
like oh [ __ ] they got their wife with
them and their kids
and then they're trying to hit on me
while they're there i'm like what the
hell that's
not cool don't do that to her like that
don't treat her like that
love her you love her right you know
like there's one
f one federal marshal a federal
um railroad cop from santa fe
um railroad like he likes me a lot
but he has a wife and i told him the
other day i told him i said you know
what
i said all this nice stuff that you're
saying to me say to your wife
all this stuff that you buy for me
supposedly
buy it for your wife but you should
appreciate it
because i appreciate it if i appreciate
it she'll appreciate it
and be faithful to her you know that's
what i told him
he cried i was like what the hell are
you crying for i'm just telling the
truth
i said because it's really [ __ ] up
feeling when you know your partner is
actually or your husband
is actually cheating on you because i've
had it happen to me
that's why i really don't like dating
because the majority are men
that are married and that don't want
their wife or their wife won't
give them a head or their wife won't do
this their wife won't do that that's why
they come and look for
other people they can't do it or they're
on their period or whatever you know
so like that's why i really don't like
to do it
you know i i try not to what's the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
patience
patience and perseverance
like and to listen
to listen and listen really listen like
not just sit there
and like be not here but to really
listen to people
like because everybody has everybody has
a story
everybody needs like a lady the other
day she came up to me a black lady
and she was real dirty and she said can
i speak to you for a minute and i say
yes and she goes i'm going to kill
myself today
i know you're not why do you say that
she said
you know you're the first person that i
asked
that actually said yes that you speak to
me and i saved that woman's life
she was gonna go kill herself
i seen her today so that was kind of
nice
and i seen her today and i was like wow
i was like she all cleaned up and stuff
she's staying at the other one
sheltered and she thanked me
for being being an ear so i was like wow
that's stuff like that that's that's
what and i've saved people's lives since
i've been out here
and they brought them back after
overdosing i was the only one there
so like i think there was a certain
purpose but my main purpose
was to come out my main purpose why i
am still here doing this stuff but
everything's coming together
real quick like in less than two years
instead of 25 or whatever
is because i already learned my lesson i
learned the value of money
big time i had my hands were all tore up
because
i recycle so like my hands
right now they're they're okay because i
haven't had a recycle
i have a place to stay you know i'm not
on the street i'm not dirty i'm not
touching the ground i'm not getting high
on the street or whatever but
like i value people that have
hard working hands that look really bad
i value them and i appreciate them
that's what i had i had to learn that
because i would make fun of people like
inside not make fun of them but like
be like oh i didn't want to touch their
hand or whatever and now i see
because people don't want to touch my
hands sometimes you know
and people look at me off weird and
strange and kids run for me
and i try to be nice to them you know
i'm like dang i
i'm like i'm sorry i'm so scared it's
scary to you
you know i thought okay that little kid
started crying
i was like what the heck and i told the
lady i said hey you know
you should teach your kid you know we're
not that bad
you know where they grab their purse and
i'm like
and i'm like [ __ ] my purse is a louis
vuitton
yours is a fake one what the hell you
know you're
why are you holding your purse i should
be holding mine you know
like people are just scary they it's
just a stereotyping of everybody
the way people perceive us as homeless
you know like it's total i don't know
all right tiffany all right thank you so
much thank you so much for sharing your
story all right
thank you
you